political parties in America have been
at war over abortion for decades more
voters than ever before say that their
vote in the 2020 presidential election
will hinge on abortion the abortion
debate has been one of the most
contentious aspects of American politics
it's even more polarized now really than
it's ever been around the quartet of
American women will have an abortion
it's an intensely emotive moral issue
across the world but only in America has
it divided politics so deeply you can
take the baby and rip the baby out of
the womb of the mother that's not okay
with me
it is her body it is her right it is her
decision
[Music]
dr. Colleen McNicholas is about to
provide testimony in a case that could
close the state of Missouri's last
surviving abortion clinic with this
trial here this week we are fighting for
our right to be able to provide access
to abortion care in 1982 Missouri had 29
abortion providers dr. McNicholas runs
the last remaining one the ability for
our clinic here to provide care is
really hanging by a thread the state of
Missouri has refused to renew the
clinics license over an alleged series
of deficiencies all truth and nothing
but the truth I do abortion has always
been hard to provide in Missouri
Missouri is one of the most restricted
states in this country but over the last
few years it has gotten incredibly and
exponentially more difficult the number
of hoops that patients have to jump
through before they can even get through
this door is astounding if the court
upholds the state's decision Missouri
would become the first state in America
with no legal abortion clinic we every
year face attack after attack both from
our state legislature and now from our
Department of Health and that's not just
local narrative that's across the whole
country
[Music]
abortion is one of the most politically
divisive subjects in America and it's
very much along partisan lines
Republican states are hostile to
abortion while democratic states are
pro-choice but this political
polarization is a peculiarly American
phenomenon in the rest of the world
abortion is legal on request or under a
broad range of circumstances in 80
countries in most of these countries
legalization has settled the debate not
stoked it take Britain abortion was
legalized here in 1967 around the same
time as America Britain legalized
abortion through a parliamentary act so
there was a long debate between MPs
about the precise details of this and
that has largely settled it as a
political issue in the country Island a
religious country like America only
recently voted to legalize abortion here
too the debate has dropped off the
political agenda
you had a substantial majority voting in
favor of abortion in that public
referendum two-thirds of people
supported it that gave real legitimacy
to the law that followed
so why didn't that happen in America the
answer partly lies in the way abortion
was legalized in the Supreme Court in
the 1973 court case Roe versus Wade
commonly known as row 9 judges ruled 72
that abortion is a constitutional right
in a landmark ruling the Supreme Court
today legalized abortions the fact that
it was a court decision rather than
legislation means that you you don't
have democratic legitimacy this wasn't a
decision that people had sort of really
come to you as a country you don't get
the details that you would in
legislation and so it means that
America's laws on abortion are actually
some of the most permissive in the world
you can have abortions far later into
pregnancy than you can in most other
countries and that has really fueled the
debate
since that landmark case public opinion
has remained remarkably constant with
the majority saying abortion should be
legal in certain cases yet politically
it has polarized with both parties
moving to the extremes but it wasn't
always this way in the 70s you could
find pro-life and pro-choice people in
both parties and in fact during the 1976
election both presidential candidates
tried very hard to distance themselves
from any strong stand on abortion if
anything Republicans were more
pro-choice than Democrats
the main opponents to abortion
immediately after Rome were Catholics
who tended to be Democrat it wasn't at
all inevitable that there would be any
party alignment on abortion much less
the one we have now
the divide was partly engineered by Paul
Warrick a right-wing strategist who in
1979 saw a political opportunity
evangelicals made up 29% of the
population abortion was his ticket to
win their vote many of them had not been
voting at all and had seen politics as
sort of evil corrupt and to some extent
largely irrelevant
Paul Wyrick thought that 'evanchelical
z' could bring elections home for
Republicans in 1980 Republican Ronald
Reagan's presidential campaign
capitalized on abortion despite
previously signing into law the most
liberal abortion bill in the country he
went on to switch his view and call for
abortion to be banned its regard to
abortion there's one individual who's
not being considered at all that's the
one who's being aborted it was a crucial
factor in his win he became the sort of
standard bearer for the idea that the
Republican Party should oppose abortion
this vote running formula has shaped
Republican politics ever since President
Trump too has gone from being pro-choice
I'm very pro-choice to a pro-life
crusade oh the baby is born and then the
doctor and the mother determined whether
or not they will execute the baby I
don't
in the 2016 presidential election mr.
Trump won eighty-one percent of the
evangelical vote president Trump has
used some of the most extreme rhetoric
we've seen on abortion he's gone out of
his way to reassure the anti-abortion
movement the fact that abortion is still
at the heart of party politics in
America means it matters more than ever
to voters 27% of Americans say a
candidate must share their views on
abortion that's a third more than for
the presidential election in 2016
under mr. Trump's administration
Republican states have ramped up their
attack on abortion access nine states
have passed so-called heartbeat bills
that would ban abortions after six or
eight weeks but they all violate the
rights granted in Roe vs. Wade so cannot
be put into effect if one of these bills
makes it to the Supreme Court however
everything could change and that's what
the pro-life is passing on accounting on
political tactics are also affecting
women's access to abortion now since
2017 35 Republican states have attempted
to strangle abortion access with more
than 250 new regulations in Missouri
women have an initial consultation then
have to wait 72 hours before returning
for their abortion for some this means
traveling 300 miles back and forth it's
a fact that dr. McNicholas is keen to
report in court most patients don't have
the opportunity come back in 72 hours
for most patients it takes them at least
a weekend sometimes much longer as they
again have to navigate many of the the
restrictions the long drives and the
figuring out gas in childcare and time
off of work
if Missouri's last clinic closes nearly
1.4 million women would be left without
statewide abortion access patients would
most likely have to cross from
Republican Missouri into democratic
state Illinois where protection for
abortion has been signed into law now
the political battle over abortion is
literally being fought across state
lines
Illinois knows where we stand and we're
going to be here for women if they have
to be refugees from other states
Illinois has opened a new mega clinic
just ten minutes from the border to
cater for the abortion demand for women
in nearby Republican states the reality
is starkly different for patients who
have the opportunity to get that care in
a dignified manner when they decide they
need it it's one of several democratic
states creating legal frameworks to
protect the right to abortion many of
the bills you see now are States both
liberal and conservative preparing for
what many believe is a post real world
and many experts myself included think
that that's a matter not of if but of
when the fate of Roe rests on the
Supreme Court which is made up of nine
justices two of whom have been appointed
by President Trump Patrick has a new
Supreme Court justice this morning Brett
Cavanaugh was sworn in overnight he's
nominated two justices to the Supreme
Court who were chosen I think with the
expectation that they would vote to
overturn Roe legal abortion this and
real peril in a way that hasn't been the
case in literally probably forty years
the newly composed Supreme Court will be
deciding on its first abortion case by
June 2020 all the signs are there that
there would be more likely a significant
scaling back of abortion rights if that
happens you'll expect to see even more
state restrictions that will be designed
to encourage the court to overturn Roe
and you'll see the court probably begin
down a path to the eventual overruling
of Rhoads if ro as I've attained
decisions about abortion will be handed
back to the states
meaning Republican states may ban
abortions outright we can see from other
countries experiences and from history
that when women can't get safe legal
abortions it means that they get
dangerous illegal ones and that they
risk their fertility their health and
even their lives ultimately it's these
women their bodies and their health that
will pay the price for the politics of
abortion for me and for my colleagues
who sit with patients every single day
and hear story after story about why
abortion is pivotal to their existence
in that moment it's not political at all
you
thanks for watching if you want to learn
more about abortion in America you can
click on the link opposite where you'll
find further economists coverage some
research data and studies we used to
make this film if you want to watch more
films like this then don't forget to
subscribe see you next time